yeah hello this is just a short video to  ya to give some information to you  unfortunately we had to reschedule for  the live event this evening evening it  is in Europe um instead of nine p.m.  central european time it is now 8 p.m.  so one hour earlier yeah this makes it  five pm on the US is it five no it makes  it 3 i'm sorry 3pm you're on the US east  coast ya better check those can those  world clock websites on the internet to  be sure it is some from this from the  point that this video is uploaded it's  just one hour so it's very short notice  I'm sorry it's a change that was  necessary due to ICC scheduling  conflicts so we're going to start one  hour earlier than was originally  announced on Monday yeah thanks for that  I hope you join anyway bye until then